do we wanna play mammy - I'm really
looking forward to this game in
particular what's wrong
nothing it's gonna be great exactly
nothing's wrong with monopoly are you in
the game or what I've been here for a
long time
wait join the game we swear to God we
saying you I sent you an invite wait
wait all right wait I don't see you're
in the game starts in two minutes wait
I'm looking for your invite I don't see
it wait what I join you I'm [ __ ]
trying mark join me literally the moment
the game existed I think it's working
now am I here oh you click it join likes
whoa how did you get purple what'd you
do did you click start no I just clicked
enter on the head what oh I see I see oh
good thing I pissed what are there any
custom rules to wish you know about its
speed dice so it's meant to be a faster
game but otherwise it didn't indicate
any custom rules so no free parking
money no double anything on go nothing
like that no shouldn't be alright oh I
roll the dices oh yeah for that's what's
up I think those people should be
worried about being crushed feel to it
you guys want monopoly you get what you
is unfounded
I've just had a bad history of this game
causing issues everything ruins
friendships ruins families where his
life causes default divorce
gabor like Congress with the cons
divorce plans are we gonna get divorced
stop it yeah oh well thanks for all say
nice stick roll bro thanks man watch
this move
[Applause]
feel like you're being a bad sport
somehow we need to calm down and just
actually try and have fun yeah I'm
trying to maybe I feel now that bob has
pointed it out you are being a little
bit you got Saint Charles please are you
doing something right now I didn't know
I needed and my turn no I didn't
understand what was happening either all
right wait I'm rollin this game works
great why is it that's one of the
personal places Wallace look at that oh
[Music]
look at that that's a different number
price blue good job see my car go vroom
vroom oh yeah
for many vroom you won't you may not
oxygen it's up baby no I want it I'm
Connecticut Avenue boy call me big can't
a connect connect to Connecticut Avenue
boy oh you're about the mortgage
property go ahead how do I know it's the
backspace button click on it no yeah I
bought it I bought it all right here we
go baby here we go big Tennessee now
yeah man auction damn it dude I'm gonna
buy it all right here we go I'm gonna
sell it to oh okay no that's pretty good
that's pretty yeah oh I got say James my
favorite of the same
it's by that Sh is done on it land on it
you won't feel like you're being really
aggressive here I'm not you are alright
I really just wanna how are you doing
buy a house but I can't for some reason
you can't accompany the electric company
hell yeah I want the electric up all
nice that's good oh good show good show
you see wait one of us is supporting the
other I'm what I'm supporting dude I
hope you get a good one see but you're
being like be like passive in you guys
are just reading into this in a weird
way I am genuinely happy for you go when
your emotions are obvious because of the
way you talk I'll take that thank you
sorry I was being supportive I guess I
should say oh [ __ ] you
why would you say that I'm in aa because
I'm not allowed to say nice things
apparently why I don't know you have to
say actually nice things not
passive-aggressive they're nice I can
get on a railroad now Atlanta Georgia oh
it's Venture Avenue Bendtner then not
venture Oh Vince noir the hardest one to
pronounce a good roll good roll
good roll is that a big red baby
Kentucky
oh yeah it's Kentucky give me a Kentucky
next door he has Tennessee you have
kentucky I'll buy Ohio technically it's
Kentucky Avenue I'm really concerned you
don't understand this this is a city
where there is none it's not important
to know what it's No
can't be right it's not important enough
you wrong-o get a mark I think that's a
trains no you should have mortgaged that
Wade your your advice is not really that
good I assure ya hey I am all about
mortgaging and tell you what it's like
for myself no I'm not drawing a card
that should go out in prison I don't
think that's what that car does but room
room it's a wiggly car I think it's a
chest no I am yeah I'm buying that oddly
topical all right guys watch this okay
what'd you do this wait no business oh
that is what I'm talking about
thank you I know well at least you broke
even
yeah parently there supposed to be a
speed die that comes into play at some
point that we have not experienced yet
even though this is speed die mode I'll
get it just give me time if I have
anything you're interested in I love
those railroads men I love them love
them they are good they're very good hey
I'm gonna land on borrowed a Czech
community chance button that is
yes I wish there was a button to just be
like don't pay him 50 and see what
happens
oh there's a button for trade oh [ __ ]
trade right now well I'm just looking
I'm just looking god you know it's fine
you know that's not the buttons that's
the buttons there we go
man I'm bad at like you are you are
discovering all the buttons early on I'm
I'm not pressing any buttons I'm using
the entirely the mouse oh that's the
fast you go Oh speedy do okay it's my
property
just just visiting a place after I made
by give you the $10 no there's big old
turd on the bed Oh your pants marks some
more money no you're gonna pass don't
worry okay thank you
what you pay me yeah it hurts
I'll even turn on your power line I want
you to do that wait turn no it's a
[ __ ] bird man not me the symbols on
the throne oh oh baby a double oh who
[ __ ] is that no that's mine okay good
good good good go man you go speed dice
again I [ __ ] hope so Wow holy [ __ ]
worry I'm on oranges I just bought New
York I just moved like a dozen spaces
okay what does that mean cool I'm in the
lead now [ __ ] alright
Oh kitty cat fell over oh man don't wait
let it let it count 13 it didn't know
anything it just it just zooms you're in
the red stuff god
the speed dye [ __ ] gets crazy beep -
happening guys I'm gonna buy a property
now it's buy one
all right ready you're calm you you
gotta you got a boss yeah yeah I did bus
Oh shoes I move two squares 3:05 whoa
no plea no one owns Virginia yet so I'll
just move to that's cool
yeah we'll buy that wow you get to
decide out what do you get to go
that cool that's klutz that's neat arene
oh yeah the bus is good I thought was
gonna go to prison I don't care why the
speed dad just comes in at an arbitrary
moment o'clock
one six or seven you get to move one
free Parks get me anything though no six
gets me to the railroad hell yeah it
does
wait you really slept on the opportunity
to get that other 8 huh I know I really
did I did you did good job guys and
that's genuine not being a dick yeah no
that sounded genuine actually yeah it
did good I'm glad you guys are finally
understanding my genuine man I wish you
could see more for the board at one time
all right mark owns a lot of expensive
property yeah I do yeah do baby yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's go shall we
you got chance not community borough's I
need community [ __ ] chance that's not
very nice thing to say to chance
double a double guy run my chat said
that that takes you to some specific
property when you get that Oh
Community Chest
[Applause]
I need money
oh here we go again boy oh you and your
[ __ ] double whoa whoa Plus is back
baby
all right four six you want to I think
all right I own a solid four properties
I'm gonna I'm gonna catch up right now
now's my time all right there you go all
right what the dude it doesn't do
anything I think he went to six works
all right
listen to Wade I got the Electric
Company you've got a railroad you're
right I'll give you water works way that
mean I'll take it I guess that's what
you want to do bus
oh I can move to to you is that the one
you own no I was ready when you own yeah
that [ __ ] yeah give me that good fine
good fine daddy wants the short line
daddy and daddy like well I don't like
that next on owned property here here
just so I don't want but don't want it
really sounds like you want I hate you
want that I'll give you that plus a
little months you want some months no I
want something good I don't want shady
[ __ ] all right
no months no months I got a I got a you
wanna you want one of these on top of it
I know a little good in orange
I'll take it orange how do I get rid of
The Electric Company okay so I put the
orange down there so what if we what if
we Fairtrade orange for railroad I can't
do you have to add it I think I can't do
anything I can't do anything either
oh I not me all right deal
I hate it but you know what won't fine
just for the sake of moving on let's do
it let me do it I had to sit there and
watch that trade we stood up for that
log so whatever
it's not intuitive Holly [ __ ] what did
you just roll dude I have the biggest
rolls the best roll and Wow I love
paying at my own properties because that
hey Mark give me that no no no no what
do you want for Tennessee mark I'll
trade with you I won't trade Jack
doodlee that got some good stuff we've
got mr. will bore you to death to make
you trade we got mister I won't trade no
matter what I trade under the right
circumstances so rude
I'm a rude in a nice loving [ __ ] way
no say that you are that thing if I
declare it it must be true all right
anyway I'll give you all my money for
Boardwalk
you know that's tempting Bob but I don't
want you giving it to mark no why would
I do that that's crazy
you crazy man you crazy no no I just
have to figure out how to get a Park
Place out of marks hands that's the
thing the property wait if bob was even
remotely serious and he offered you all
of his money for boardwalk why wouldn't
you give it to you I D wouldn't I'll do
it I'll do it right now you'll give me
$1,500 for boardwalk only if you'll be
patient enough to watch me set up the
trade oh no it's going we're getting
there Oh getting closer getting closer
all right to be fair you said $1,500 so
that's what I'm gonna go with and that's
the one boom wait why didn't I hang on
so how do i there we go ah man man that
is so tempting
Wow you just let me do every turn I'm
gonna offer you 1,500 bucks
oh no oh no minion zero seven seven
seven what that your name I don't know
I've got eight of these accounts I'm on
I guess I understand your life I
understand anything you do don't account
but it was me you know I got boardwalk
what I feel like that's not true
you want it if I'm reading you right no
way I'm gonna have boardwalk don't worry
about it look I'm working on an angle to
Red's you have two Reds so like we'll
set up like at a contention deal I don't
have for walk in my possession but like
I have 4y speaking uh-huh mark give me
two reds uh-huh and I will give Bob
boardwalk mark I'm still following this
deal I'm in I'm in what is utility sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know this
mark I'm totally into it I'm more into
it than you are
you won't I'm more I'm I'm the most into
it actually
ooh which one is this
Atlantic Avenue Illinois action great
everyone I [ __ ] get two of ours got
the goddamn third and he's like the
least available person kind of made an
offer but it wasn't genuine offer I know
dice what the [ __ ] oh good I'm visiting
prison that's where I want them is wrong
on your stream information that's that
not my problem
actually it sounds like it is my problem
so the term of the dice a little less
aggressive I don't even know what I'm
doing her Who I am anymore
oh god I'm staying at his own house I
got so much good stuff dude check it out
check me out check it out check check
which one are you again this you I'm new
I got one of those Reds I got one of
those greens I got three out of four
railroads would you get lose you don't
one of those what would you want for
that red way to say no but Park Place
would be fine with me Park Place for
that financially I will yeah yeah yeah I
will take that alright I think I'm down
for that interesting trait cuz and it
does give you a full set but how do we
shift and yeah that's like not a very
intuitive thing but okay yeah yeah I'm
into that
alright oh god what why doesn't it just
say enter space shift the little symbols
confuse me all right so you guys trading
me try two three railroads four and the
other utility you'd be like a mogul you
know cool sets yeah I'll give you the
utility no no no seriously having all
those set I hate the railroads I don't
want them I mean so what are you trying
to get Park Place out of me cuz that's
gonna be real easy to accomplish
all right I did it how do I know what am
i doing see you you're laughing to me
when I was mortgaging my properties but
it's [ __ ] complicated sometimes why
did the dice always land like this
get it at your key harder rolls them
better wait hello got some good stuff
over here wid ya asking what do you need
he wants your yellow probably my yellow
what would you do with my yellow what
would you do wear your orange he wants
you have to two of his thirds let him
say though I want to hear the coward
he's he's not yeah he's not gonna face
you down he's not muted wait are you
just not talking no what do you want out
of this mess good pitch good pitch I
mean I'd do a boardwalk I don't I can
give you two thirds of two sets I give
you boardwalk I've also got this lovely
thing that Bob same as a chair all
worthless I give me dosh or death he
doesn't need you mad money I've been
away for too long my turn will be
bypassed but right here looking at stuff
why is it I'm not here got a hurry up
bro got a hurry up bro all right what do
you want mark just told you he wants
money gosh
how much money a lot which one did you
want coming the devil Oh baby what it
what what did i do why is this happening
are you going bankrupt right now I don't
understand
whoa I got to pick
I rolled a triple so I got okay that's
what's up what is up well I got two of
those greens now how you feeling mark
how you livin being inactive and says
I'm gonna be fitting the game soon click
something how do I get all the way over
here all right hey mark now we talk hey
buddy what hey how do I he doesn't want
that shitty chain one hook up you're bad
at this
Bob what do you want for what do you got
what do you want Chris I'll take
boardwalk for two greens okay all right
that's something that's that's what you
have that interests me
boardwalk sounds good okay and I've got
a train Bob know you want that train to
now so let's uh let's let's start
negotiating here I'm gonna go [ __ ]
quick as [ __ ] so I don't goddamn lose
everything
so you want this and you want that and
you'll offer me what two greens and
maybe I know how much that greens are
worth but let's see what that value is
yeah pretty bleak for my stash stay with
me but the two greens and maybe that
light blue now you may have to do it
wait I have to point out to you hit
shifting to monopolise for just two
generic properties right no no no he's
working on it hand so actually they're
even value right there 650 600 are not
don't you try to pull anything here in
value they are absolutely not even value
are you kidding me
wait if you want wait if you want all if
you want all of those I also want
electric company whoa whoa you don't
like the utilities be fooled you are
kidding oh no monopolies out of this box
exactly you're getting a monopoly if you
take electric company I'm not giving you
four for two listen you know that I'm
not Keith okay uh don't let him fool you
for for two wouldn't be fair for you in
this exchange he would have to give you
all of his myself for that
my work is over Sully are you alright
mark now you know I got some wheeling
alright yeah let's do this I want to
negotiate with you so I'm just gonna
give everyone else everything they want
is the green set or some [ __ ] it's fine
mark I want from you
yes I'll actually give you greens and
what else what I give you you can find
out again you're just gonna do some
traits and then not move I'll give you
greens and two blues oh my [ __ ] dude
what are you doing to me right there oh
my god scored
you know what just to make it
interesting I'm accepted I was trying to
be the psychopath you know I just how do
you build [ __ ] start your green great no
okay
all right man this is slow going isn't
it only if you do it slow all right I
don't know how to how do I stop now Oh
God all right this game's gonna be over
in four turns now when we all land on
blue about this I just want to know wait
I just wanted to get the trades done and
wait no you knew you knew that was a bad
deal right you knew that right yeah I
need you to tell me you knew that I know
you knew the
I gave you green and bob blue of course
I know I'm [ __ ] you you [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] me good people you're too great
okay nevermind Oh barely buying houses
means I don't get to roll Oh
what oh yeah that's why I didn't get to
roll Oh realize that was the rules
ah good railroad ah yes oh yes excellent
excellent excellent good good
at least those are only ever 200 or 400
been excellent I excellent
a plan for the future here oh yeah you
think you think it's junk I think I
think I'm done okay listen you took
logic out of this game man you took
reasoning you took strategy out of it
you took everything out of it I feel
like I did good for the good of us who's
us collectively OGE player 50 bucks a
hell yeah another house on that Prop
we're just gonna it's gonna be great
there we go
that's nice man nice all right there we
go we're just gonna all go bankrupt here
real quick yeah yes oh snap [ __ ] balls
think I'm the monopoly here mark it's
not good oh did I get the brown one oh
yeah no you already own that one no
that's the one I already have
I'm just choice I thought the guy moved
you to a property you didn't own I don't
know apparently not I feel misled I
don't understand anything what's
happening oh is not a good thing that's
happening to me right now
oh no it's it's fine that's fine Oh
ninety bucks that's more than double
what I've already got
Hey look at that yeah yeah man hey all
right mark roll roll a nice big fun I'm
gonna do it 12 for me I got is kill your
kid I don't like it cuz chaos reigns in
this game please
move forward for me uh no I don't think
that's going to happen with ya 700 700
there's no house on that one all right
watch out big moneybags
every last cent play on the edge all
right Wade roll big real real real loud
tasty one I sure did it's gonna hurt oh
yeah I don't have houses on that what
does it matter
you're both set up real nice it's been
three turns since you traded me these
greens I still think you're trying to
upsell them okay room room room any room
let's get out of here mice will do that
I guess buy some of these up that's fine
god I wish I could just go like straight
to like hotel or whatever for the record
these Browns are not my fault
those Browns are indirectly your fault
no Bob you don't want that you guys
definitely you guys are definitely gonna
land on these last house in the bank the
bank has limited houses oh I didn't
realize that was a thing Oh barely tops
one house I get a discount oh you guys
can't baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
or some more money and then later we'll
all have some fun unknown property
what's that I don't think there are any
unknown property dice property that's
what I wanted from you yeah
that's just great I know what I could
buy my own house I got this big I want
to go to high oh well let's just do this
whoa you can get that you do it
I got everybody thank you for minimizing
the price I had Japan that I appreciate
that mark just for the record
without any goddamn money well the real
question is where to put it you know the
thing is I had the money to buy it I did
I did have the money I guess I'm done
right now my next property what's this
[ __ ] I'm uh boy that's that's rough
no no it's fine that's a rough one
you've got this oh you got it oh my god
that's brutal hey thanks for the money
dude two bucks to work with man how many
cheeseburgers is that enough to feed the
the Clemson football team at the White
House your tropical let's jam that right
in there huh please what the [ __ ] is
this oh I get to choose great that's
what you deserve
man I should have kept those thank you
how are you did you just mortgage the
purple ones wait is that what you just
mortgage i mortgaged the ox the house
the electrical utility the utility there
okay it's technically cheapest on two I
guess really lost out man sweet twelve
bucks you got there though in hindsight
huh where do I put this free house you
did what you did it wrong sold your
house what you sold your house I thought
I owned the last house why couldn't I
wait at night but I think you thought
that's not what I wanted yeah that's not
good
all right I hit the wrong one well
there's a house on the market boys great
yeah mark and I'll fight over it you'll
take it else yeah I'll get you good I'll
get you man yeah yeah you know what I
believe thank you
I can't believe there's a limited number
of goddamn houses I'm not played is it
so long okay I can't I know that was a
game rule I just thought that was like
the number of peace
they gave you I just want this move
stupid no buddy you know what there's
gonna be a it's fine it's fine
who do you owe me money me up with love
you got a baby listen dying my money I'm
gonna buy a goddamn house in a few turns
you got it man I didn't realize there
was a house on that one because I
couldn't see down the board
I stood still have the free house hey
baby I don't really want to play again
but they said I have to yeah I don't
know how to place the Oh big roll good
play good play good play good play
I don't know where this this take it
take it my boy ticket hey how do I place
my on the plus just click on it it's not
doing anything okay there we go all
right okay weird I don't understand why
that happened you you want to put it
there just gonna cost you 200 no it's
gonna be yeah I'll let you guys fight
over it that's not the button how do I
get out of here there we go
you guys can you can you man you really
[ __ ] ape that cat I really do man I
really do okay baby Lots alice is on
that one yeah really
oh that's not quite high enough probably
you're not gonna have enough months for
that I don't think $200 give our
paychecks to Bob
all right good play good play
all right now I'm coming into the pain
lanes wait guys land on my property no
one's letting my [ __ ] car all right
never mind go see mark you will this
deal yeah you win you right you right
you right you right you win you're right
you right you right you right you right
which one is this [ __ ] this is so
[ __ ] confusing can i mortgage that
yes that one and can i mortgage this one
yes good you sure you're the blues and
the greens nah it's fine this fine
sure it can I pay you yet oh it's 750 of
course it is Boop and a Boop uh-huh
that's the amount I need it there we go
my god test it I'm gonna get it oh nice
doubles buddy it's what your big
romantic rolls roll rolling oh yeah
$700 I'll give you a
get-out-of-jail-free to chill right now
how do you get to do profits definitely
I do [ __ ]
it's always the expensive one isn't it I
think so
and over there more houses oh [ __ ] I
thought was there - hey buddy do you
wanna if you lend me 40 bucks I'll buy a
house all right no man I won't oh wait
wait oh I just sold houses that's why I
supposed to pay you there's more houses
happening bro
yeah the tables are turning my man holy
[ __ ] he's gonna have a hotel which means
that there's houses for sale all right
with my sixty bucks I won't buy any
other but mail I got this I feel good
yeah I like how you're zeroing out just
as you're coming around to the no no
that's too much it's chillin I'm good
man I'm good here I am good happy as a
lark sick roll
sick roll say thank you thank you very
sick disgusting even ah what a good turn
I had I would love to buy a property but
a house but you know they were past this
turn roll though that's really high
that's a double Oh baby I can't even
afford $50 that's not good why not Bob
and everyone said it was wait stop the
second one of us it's blue we are dead
do you real help no no he's gonna have
to sell it soon you're getting rich sure
seven sounds good
I own this property oh boy be $1,400
good good gracious I hope no one has to
pay me that much anything even remotely
close to that you know I think on your
third roll in jail mark you have to pay
like 200 to get out so I'm gonna start
mortgage you [ __ ] this I'm out you
douchebag
wait Wow repent god I gotta keep the
mortgage on all your shul I only
mortgaged one property man you did okay
yeah I'm good I think it sells all my
house though Oh Bobby laughs I'm good no
you wanna play this one out twits nah
I'm good
I think even if I sold my houses and
mortgaged everything I wouldn't made
$1,100
you had you owned like ten houses I had
50 50 50 100 hundred hundred was that
like 500 600 they're from houses yeah
yeah I was that was the end yeah oh wait
Bob why'd you quit you're the blues mark
why'd you have to play this one out
[Laughter]
[Music]
you